Hello everyone,
and thank you for taking the time to join
us today.
I'm excited to walk you through our key
client requirements or KCR solution.
Let's dive into how this tool works.
The process starts when the appraiser
uploads the appraisal report document to
the DDR UI as shown here.
Once the document is uploaded to the Box
folder,
the AI tool automatically kicks in and
starts processing the PDF.
The AI processes the document and
extracts the relevant information based
on predefined prompts and client
requirements.
This eliminates the need for appraisers
to go through the report manually,
which saves a significant amount of time.
After processing the document,
the AI generates an Excel report.
Once the report is generated,
the appraiser receives an automatic
e-mail notification.
This e-mail contains the generated report
and Excel ready for the appraiser to
review and verify the information quickly.
The appraiser can then validate the
report against the source material,
ensuring that the AI has correctly
interpreted the document.
Here you can see the Excel file that's
generated.
It includes all sections,
checklist questions and the AI extracted
information and validation status.
The appraiser can easily review the key
information and validated it and confirm
if any changes are required.
This report contains validation topics,
AI extracted values and metadata from the
PDF.
It also compares these again the source
data from the Letter of engagement
document and TOPS to database.
Each requirement is marked met or not met
to ensure accuracy.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.